it doesn't matter if you're a die-hard
Appel supporter or a Samsung fanboy the
new Google pixel 4 is definitely
something to admire what's going on guys
my name is David Tommy and welcome back
to the channel today we're talking about
the up-and-coming Google pixel 4 and the
Google pixel for excel so far we've had
a lot of rumors and a lot of leaks come
out about the pixel 4 as we know that
the anticipated launch date is October
15th 2019 so in less than a week's time
we are going to see the brand-new pixel
4 unveiled to the whole world
there's lots we know about it and
there's lots we still don't know about
the phone
for starters we know Google has always
come out with the best cameras in the
pixel line so something that we can
definitely expect to see in the new
pixel 4 is an amazing camera setup on
the rear and also on the front we've had
a couple of leaked photos and a couple
videos of a hands-on with the pixel 4 so
we definitely know that it's coming out
with at least two cameras on the rear
side and one on the front side so what
we're expecting to see is a standard
camera and either a telephoto or ultra
wide preferably the ultra wide for me is
a little bit more useful than the
telephoto because you can actually zoom
in and crop in after the fact and that
way you don't really need the telephoto
too much whereas if you have more of the
picture then you definitely can get a
lot more better shots than just having a
telephoto and a zoom lens so as of right
now it's rumored that it's going to come
out at about 1,000 USD or 1500
Australian dollars this is actually a
pretty decent price tag considering all
the latest flagships from Samsung and
Apple are coming out of the 2000 the
$3,000 price tag if you're looking at
the galaxy fold so coming in a
relatively modest $1500 isn't too bad at
all so we've seen a couple linked
pictures of the new anticipate colors as
well we're actually going to get a
really cool color lineup this year from
the Google picks before we're
anticipated to get just black clearly
white and also orange
now I'm actually gonna praise Google
here for going out on the limb and
making these color names a little bit
more creative than your standard purple
blue green as other companies do now the
new iPhone 11 that came out a couple
weeks ago has a very similar camera bump
on the back as the Google pixel 4 does
but in my personal opinion the Google
pixel four's camera bump on the back the
little square notch with the different
arrangement looks so much better and so
much cleaner than the iPhone 11 does now
if you ask me the matte black version
that pixel fought with that matte black
camera bump looks pretty damn good to me
so something also that you can see from
the Vietnamese bloggers have released
these leaked images and the released
video is the simple fact that there is
no fingerprint scanner on the system
whatsoever if you're a fan of the Google
pixel range you'll know that there's
always been a fingerprint scanner on the
backside of the phone now without that
addition we can expect to see the
fingerprint scanner be put into the
display and have an ultrasonic
fingerprint scanner ready to go inside
the glass also to some people's demise
the headphone jack is completely gone
from the pixel 4 and the pixel for Excel
and no previous pixel models retained it
quite well and they allowed users to
really use their old-school headphones
but as the wireless headphone trend
becomes bigger and bigger and more and
more companies are launching new great
wireless headphones
well the necessary requirement for the
headphone jack is actually being
eliminated it's really weird to me
though that people have been able to
leak these photos and videos of the new
pixel for to the whole entire world and
to Google's competitors prior to it
being launched I know this might be a
marketing tactic somewhere deep deep
inside the company but I don't know if I
was running Google and definitely be
finding these people and firing them for
breach of contract and leaking patented
information to the entire world
now what we're expecting to see is
actually one of the largest pixels to
date we're expecting to see a 6.2 3 inch
display with 540 pixels per inch in the
solution if you have no idea what pixels
per inch means if you think of it this
way when we design images and photos for
the internet and for the screen we
always export to 72 pixels per inch when
we print high-quality photos that end up
going on Billboard's we've print at
about 300 pixels per inch so the simple
fact that the Google pixel 4 has almost
600 pixels per inch basically means that
there is going to be no visible outside
blur of any pixels or any photos that
are higher quality on this phone the
screen is exceptional quality from an
additional suspect point of view we're
looking at about 6 gigabytes of RAM up
to 128 gigabytes of storage 3700
milliamp battery in the pixel XL and the
Snapdragon 855 chipset I think that's
actually a little bit funny a little bit
of a quirky fact is that the chipset
inside this phone actually only retails
for about 60 Australian dollars which
I'm sure Google is getting at a heavily
heavily discounted price to that when
you think about it this chipset
basically powers the entire phone and
does most of the heavy lifting when you
think about the brand new Intel eye 9
chipset for high-end desktops and
rendering machines we're talking about a
thousand Australian dollars for just
that chipset so it's such a huge price
difference from a $60 snapdragon 855 to
the Intel I 9 obviously but this is also
why I usually recommend to people not to
buy a mobile chip in their laptops when
they're going out and purchasing a new
laptop even though we've actually seen
quite a lot of leaks and released images
of the device of the physical shape of
the device and all the specs that we
might be seeing inside this product what
we don't know yet is a simple fact of
all the software upgrades and the
advanced things that this Google picks
before might be able to do from recent
launches from the Samsung S 10 and the
iPhone 11 launches we've seen some great
new additions to what was previously
never implemented into phones we've seen
3d depth scanners and we've seen awesome
video stabilization in
both of these devices I'm assuming that
Google's great software package is going
to be able to take both of these things
to the next level also implementing a
brand new system of the Google I won't
say the word just to help you kind out
if you have a Google assistant but we're
also gonna be seeing some great AI in
this device and hopefully all the
software upgrades that we might be
seeing in this launch will really add to
the character of this phone I'm hoping
that one day I'm gonna be able to
replace this massive DSLR in front of me
with a single smartphone now it might
actually be the Google pixel for
depending on how good the video quality
is on it and I'm quite curious to know
if you guys are going to be able to tell
the difference when I switch out this
DSLR to a simple smartphone that's all
for me guys thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
20-19 style we're trying to make it to a
thousand subscribers before Christmas
we're definitely on the right track
thanks again for watching and as always
I'll see you next Monday